aprobado en el senado de la Reforma
pensional de macrón que eleva la edad de
jubilación de los 62 a los 64 años
195 miembros del senado votaron a favor
del texto mientras 112 votaron en contra
la primera ministra Elizabeth bug a
través de su cuenta de Twitter aplaudió
la votación tras cientos de horas de
debate el senado adoptó el texto de la
Reforma de las pensiones un paso
decisivo para llevar a cabo una reforma
que garantizará el futuro de nuestro
sistema de pensiones totalmente
comprometida para que el texto sea
adoptado definitivamente en los próximos
días pero al texto le faltan varios
pasos en el legislativo un comité
conjunto de legisladores del senado y de
la asamblea nacional discutirán el
proyecto posiblemente el miércoles si el
comité llega a un consenso el jueves se
llevará a cabo una votación final en
ambas cámaras pero el proyecto no lo
tiene tan fácil Ya que en la asamblea
nacional el partido de macron necesita
votos de los aliados para obtener la
mayoría de no llegar a este gran el
presidente puede aprobar el texto sin
este órgano a través de un controvertido
procedimiento llamado 49.3 las marchas
en contra del proyecto apenas lograron
convocar este sábado unas 368.000
personas un número inferior a las
anteriores cuando salieron a las calles
un millón de personas los sindicatos
planean mantener la presión el 63% de
los ciudadanos se opone al plan de
macron según las encuestas y solo una
pequeña mayoría apoya a las acciones de
huelga